this may be the hottest sports car ever
built the AC Cobra with more than 500
horsepower and weighing just 1000 kilos
it's hard to keep it on the ground
Aereo tesha Cobra shava aficionado loves
this combination a car that lightweight
but with a whopping 7 liters engine
displacement and a manual gearbox a very
explosive mixture in c5 he can out
decently some must even be Santa sex
proceeded in 1961 the Texan Carol Shelby
had the idea of mounting a u.s. v8
engine and an English sports car
the result is one of the fastest and
most brutal cars ever built after seven
years and not quite 1,000 dope vehicles
the original model was taken off the
market but the legend lives on in the
form of replicas like this mark 6 which
is built in Germany
Harry utage is a classy car dealer and
loves to drive a Cobra
it's most fun on well-paved and
well-maintained winding country roads
but it's rough handling is not for
everyone
the Cobra requires a very manly driving
style a clutch and steering both require
muscle power many women feel the car is
uncooperative so it's a car for real
he-men Harry meets up with them at
classy car rallies this is the sixth
edition of the original Cobra which
Carroll Shelby first built in 1965 just
300 of them
the Cobra went out of production
relatively quickly so people who loved
it considered how to keep its basic
principles going while improving some
aspects technology of these shock
absorbers today is much more elaborate
and more efficient than in the original
all the characteristic traits have
remained the bumper horns shark's mouth
grille the replicas placed the engine
further to the back it's now really a
front middle engine here fairly well
hidden is the 7 liter 8 cylinder engine
some small changes have given it about
540 horsepower something a trained eye
can spot with a look at the exhaust
system we can now show it on dollars
full Sun lager a real ball of fire and
the guise of a classic Harry's Cobra
leaves plenty of the newest sports cars
in the dust
Nicolle by the cobra is a dedicated
accelerator for example Harry is doing
60 kilometers an hour in third gear when
he steps on the gas the car clocks 110
kilometers an hour in the twinkling of
an eye and the engine performs similarly
in every gear for Harry that's the
defining characteristic of a Cobra
fast faster Cobra the mark 6 accelerates
from 0 to 100 kilometres an hour in a
miniscule 3.3 seconds no wonder the rear
tires wear down so fast in a cobra the
Cobras limits are absolutely honest have
you opened the throttle too much the
rear fishtails
but that's something you can play with
something to learn to deal with in
reaching optimal speed in a cobra is a
question of accustoming yourself of
talent and of engaging with the car
talent and character are needed to charm
the Cobra if you don't control it with
an iron hand you'll end up scraping
along the guardrail theoretically the
Cobra tops out at 300 kilometres an hour
what driver has that much courage
it's not surprising to hear that the
cobra has some features borrowed from
the racetrack like the original Cobra
427 this replica has a llamar fuel tank
cap but it has been changed to fit the
times and modern fuel nozzles the
exhaust system is a less obtrusive
underfloor arrangement the old sports
versions generally had side pipes
mounted on the left and right in the
vehicle 20 of at first that's impressive
but the noise gets on one's nerves
fairly quickly though it's dug on you
since the interior of the replica is the
same as in the original there are a few
electrical switches for windshield
wipers the horn and other details
typical are these AC and Smith
instruments which run in opposite
directions the rev counter runs in a
counterclockwise direction the
speedometer clockwise vertically good
replicas cost between 50 and 150
thousand Europe's surviving originals
can fetch up to a million and a half
people didn't buy and maintain these
cars to go for a leisurely Sunday drive
in the country they wanted these cars in
order to use them and so the individual
parts often show extreme wear if you're
buying one you have to pay close
attention to the brakes axles engine
transmission synchronization a lot of
engine and a minimum of car that's the
mixture that is excited Harry for a
quarter of a century now
this is thoughts of money Harry is proud
of his 427 mark 6 AC Cobra it's one he
finds most drivable and he's had plenty
of other Cobras for comparison he says
he wants to grow old with it or take it
into his grave caught them by leaping
photo and when a veteran dealer and
classy car says that it means something
you